>> SEVERAL VICTIMS REMAIN
HOSPITALIZED AND WE SHOULD NOTE
THIS MARKS THE THIRD MASS
SHOOTING IN VIRGINIA IN FEWER
THAN TWO WEEKS.
LET'S TAKE YOU TO THE SCENE NOW
WITH CNN'S BRIAN TODD WHO IS LIVE
THERE FOR US, BRIAN, WHAT ARE WE
LEARNING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED?
>> Reporter: RIGHT, BORIS, AND
TO REITERATE THE NEW REPORTING
FROM CNN THAT THE SHOOTER'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS ANDRE BING, WE GOT
A STATEMENT FROM WALMART A SHORT
TIME AGO.
I WILL AED READ PART OF IT.
THE WALMART -- THIS IS ACCORDING
TO SCOTT POPE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
GLOBAL COMMUNICATIONS WHO SENT
CNN A STATEMENT SAYING THE
ALLEGED SHOOTER HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS ANDRE BING.
WE CAN CONFIRM THAT HE WAS A
WALMART ASSOCIATE.
ANDRE'S POSITION WITH THE
COMPANY WAS OVERNIGHT TEAM LEAD
EMPLOYED WITH US SINCE 2010 AND
SAY THEY ARE THANKFUL FOR THE
FIRST RESPONDERS AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
CASE.
WE HAVE BEEN PRESSING WALMART
ALL DAY ON WHETHER THERE WERE
ANY DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS
INITIATED AGAINST THIS EMPLOYEE
OR WHETHER ANY OTHER EMPLOYEES
HAD COMPLAINED ABOUT HIM.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN AN
ANSWER FROM WALMART ON THAT YET.
BUT WHAT WE DO HAVE IS AN
ACCOUNT FROM BRIANA TYLER, AN
EMPLOYEE WHO EARLIER SPOKE TO
ABC NEWS AND WAS TELLING US THAT
THE SHOOTER WAS A MANAGER WHO
SHE WAS TOLD TO, QUOTE, LOOK OUT
FOR BECAUSE THERE WAS ALWAYS
SOMETHING GOING ON WITH HIM.
JUST HAVING ANG ISSUE WITH
SOMEONE, END QUOTE.
SHE SAID THAT SHE HAD BEEN
GATHERED WITH HER CO-WORKERS IN
A BREAK ROOM JUST BEFORE THEIR
SHIFT STARTED.
SHE LOOKED UP AND HER MANAGER
OPENED THE DOOR, WHEN THEY SAW
THE SHOOTER OPENING FIRE, SHE
SAID.
SHE TOLD ABC THAT HE WAS NOT
AIMING AT ANYONE SPECIFICALLY,
THAT HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
WHILE SHOOTING.
AND THAT HE LOOKED DIRECTLY AT
HER.
BUT MISSED HER HEAD BY AN INCH
OR TWO BUT THIS WAS AN ACCOUNT
FROM AN EMPLOYEE WHO SAYS THAT
SHE WAS TOLD TO LOOK OUT FOR
HIM.
AGAIN, WE HAVE PRESSED WALMART
ON THAT TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAD
COMPLAINED ABOUT HIM.
IF THERE WAS ANYTHING THAT WAS
SAID OR ENACTED.
ANY COMPLAINTS FILED ABOUT HIM
TO WALMART THAT MAYBE HAD NOT
BEEN ACTED UPON.
THEY HAVE NOT RESPONDED TO THAT
YET OR QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
ANY DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS HAD
BEEN INITIATED BUT WE DO HAVE
THE NAME OF THE SUSPECT ANDRE
BING AND ACCORDING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS HE KILLED
SIX INSIDE THE STORE AND THEN
TURNED THE GUN ON HIMSELF.
BORIS, WE WERE TOLD BY POLICE HE
USED A PISTOL AND PRESSED THEM
ON WHETHER OTHER WEAPONS WERE
USED.
THEY HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF ANY
OTHER WEAPONS, BORIS.
>> WE APPRECIATE YOU PRESSING
FOR THOSE ANSWERS.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS FURTHER NOW
WITH FORMER FBI SENIOR PROFILER
MARY ELLEN O'TOOLE AND JENNIFER
MA
MASIHA AT "THE TRACE."
MARY ELLEN, I WANTED TO START
WITH YOU.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS JUST STARTING
TO SHARE MORE DETAILS NOW.
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU ABOUT THIS
INCIDENT AND HEARING FROM THAT
EMPLOYEE WHO WAS TOLD TO LOOK
OUT FOR THAT MANAGER?
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU?
>> WELL, A COUPLE THINGS STAND
OUT AND THE FIRST ONE IS THAT
THE SHOOTER WALKED INTO THE
BREAK AREA WHERE HE KNEW HIS
EMPLOYEES WERE LIKELY TO BE AND
STARTED SHOOTING.
THAT CERTAINLY SUGGESTS
PLANNING.
THINKING AHEAD OF TIME HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO CARRY THIS OUT
AND THEN SECONDLY WITH THE
EMPLOYEES SAYING THAT SHE HAD
BEEN FOREWARNED THAT THERE WAS
SOME ISSUES ABOUT THIS
INDIVIDUAL SUGGEST THAT THERE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN COMPLAINTS
FORMALLY FILED WITH WALMART
ABOUT THIS PERSON AND THEIR
BEHAVIOR.
>> AND, JENNIFER, WHEN POLICE
LAID OUT THE TIME LINE, I
THOUGHT THIS WAS INTERESTING.
THERE WERE FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN
THE 911 CALL AND POLICE ENTERING
THE STORE.
THAT'S A RELATIVELY FAST
RESPONSE TIME.
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU THAT THE
SHOOTER IN THAT SHORT WINDOW WAS
ABLE TO INFLICT THAT MUCH DAMAGE
WITH A PISTOL?
>> WELL, HE WAS APPARENTLY IN A
BREAK ROOM AT CLOSE RANGE, BUT
THE MAJORITY OF GUN VIOLENCE AND
MASS SHOOTINGS ARE PERPETRATED
WITH HANDGUNS, THEY ARE
CONCEALABLE.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET THAT FAR
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WALK IN WITH
AN AR-15 BUT PLUMABLY WITH A
HANDGUN CONCEALED UNDER ACE
CLOTHES.
>> WHAT ARE THE QUESTIONS AT
THIS MOMENT FROM AN INVES
INVESTIGATIVE STANDPOINT?
CLEARLY MOTIVE BUT THE OTHER
THING THAT STRIKES ME THE JAWEED
AT THE TOP OF THE SHOW AND
WITNESS SPEAKING IN ALMOST
MATTER OF FACT TONES ABOUT THIS.
AS IF IT'S SOMETHING THEY TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
>> RIGHT.
I MEAN, IT IS PART OF OUR
CULTURE AND A PART OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THEIR 20s AND 30s.
WE DON'T CALL THEM GENERATION
LOCKDOWN FOR NOTHING.
THE 20-YEAR-OLDS LIKE THE WOMAN
OR THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM LOOKED
LIKE TALKING TO, 20 AND 30,
THEY'RE USED TO -- A GENERATION
USED TO THE IDEA OF MASS
SHOOTINGS IN A WAY THAT I THINK
PEOPLE IN THEIR 40s AND 50s ARE
NOT TALKED LIKE THAT AND ALSO IN
SHOCK SO I THINK THEIR
DESCRIPTION MAY SEEM OFFPUTTING
BUT IT MAY BE THEY HAVEN'T
PROCESSED WHAT THEY WERE CLOSE
TO.
IT IS NARROWING, THE
INVESTIGATION.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS AND
WALMARTS ARE LARGE.
IT NOW APPEARS THAT THEY -- HE'S
KNOWN, THE REASON WHY HE WAS AT
THE STORE IS KNOWN.
MAYBE WE DON'T KNOW THE TRIGGER
BUT WE KNOW THE WEAPON AND THE
VICTIMS ARE AN ISOLATED GROUP,
UNFORTUNATELY, SO THE
INVESTIGATION WILL MOSTLY AND
YOU HAVE A DEAD KILLER SO NO
TRIAL.
SO THE INVESTIGATION MOSTLY WILL
GO TO MOTIVE AT THAT PARTICULAR
MOMENT, WHAT ISSUES HE WAS GOING
THROUGH AND THEN ALSO WHAT KIND
OF SUPERVISORS KNEW HIM.
THAT WILL BE INVESTIGATED AS
WELL.
>> YOU WATCH THEM PLAY OUT AND,
AGAIN, I CAN'T FIND THE RIGHT
WORD FOR THIS, I GET DEPRESSED
EVERY TIME YOU DO ONE OF THESE
STORIES, AND SOMETIMES YOU THINK
YOU DO SO MANY YOU WOULD LEARN
TO BLAZE THROUGH IT.
A GRAPHIC.
20 MASS SHOOTINGS INVOLVING
CASUALTIES OF FIVE OR MORE
FATALITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THERE HAVE BEEN 600 PLUS MASS
SHOOTINGS IN 2022.
SAVE ME THE THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
WE NEED TO DO MORE --
>> A LOT OF US DID NOT REST WELL
AND WILL NOT UNTIL WE GET A
HANDLE ON THIS GUN VIOLENCE.
FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SAYING THAT THEIR HEARTS AND
PRAYERS GO OUT TO THESE PEOPLE.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANYMORE
ABOUT THAT UNTIL THEY GET
SERIOUS ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION.
>> IN THIS CASE THE CONGRESS IS
NOT POISED TO DO ANYTHING AT THE
MOMENT.
IN THE CASE OF A SEMI ASSAULT
WEAPON YOU HAVE ONE
CONVERSATION.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO WORKED THERE
WALKING IN WITH A PISTOL AS YOU
HEARD ONE OF THE WITNESSES
SAYING A MANAGER SHE'S BEEN TOLD
TO WATCH OUT FOR SO ANGER ISSUES
OF SOME KIND.
ANYTHING HERE FROM A LEGISLATIVE
STANDPOINT, ANYTHING THAT CAN BE
DONE?
>> WELL, THE DIFFICULT POLICY
ISSUE IS WHETHER OR NOT THE
COUNTRY OR INDIVIDUAL STATES
WANT TO TRY TO RESTRICT ACCESS
TO WEAPONS FROM A LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOMELAND SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER THERE ARE
WARNING SIGNS AND HAVING FAMILY
AND FRIENDS BRING THAT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND VIRGINIA STATE
POLICE WANT PEOPLE TO BRING
INDIVIDUALS TO THEM AND BRING
WARNINGS SO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
POTENTIALLY CAN HAVE A BETTER
IDEA OF HOW TO PREVENT IT BUT,
AT THE CENTER FOR AMERICAN
SECURITY WE DID A SURVEY OF A
FOCUSED GROUP OF CROSS SECTION
OF AMERICANS TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ARE PEOPLE MOST AFRAID
OF.
MASS SHOOTINGS BY FAR TOP THE
LIST.
WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
TIMING OF WHEN COULD WE ACTUALLY
DO THIS SURVEY WE THOUGHT, WELL,
THERE WAS JUST THE -- WE DID IT
LAST SUMMER.
THERE WAS JUST THE BUFFALO
SHOOTING AND THEN WE LOOKED AT,
WELL, WHAT IF WE WAITED A COUPLE
WEEKS AND WOULD HAVE RUN INTO
HIGHLAND PARK AND CHICAGO AND
THIS HAPPENS CONSTANTLY IN
AMERICA.
>> HAPPENS CONSTANTLY IN HAPPEN.
JULIETTE, CARRIE MENTIONED
BUFFALO, THAT WAS A SUPERMARKET.
THIS IS A WALMART.
AMONG THE SOFTER TARGETS
ESPECIALLY IN THE HOLIDAY
SEASON, EMPLOYEES GOING IN AND
OUT, PEOPLE GOING IN AND OUT AND
SOMEONE CARRYING A PISTOL, EASY
TO CONCEAL.
>> YES, I MEAN, LOOK, THERE IS
NO SOCIETY THAT YOU AND I WANT
TO LIVE IN WHERE YOU CAN BE
SAFE, RIGHT, BECAUSE -- WHAT
WOULD THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS YOUR EXPERIENCE GOING
TO THE STORE OR WALKING DOWN THE
STREET WOULD BE SO FORTIFIED
IT'S NOT EVEN WORTH IT ANYMORE
SO THE IDEA THAT WE CAN GET --
THAT WE CAN DEFEND OUR WAY INTO
THE SOLUTION IS RIDICULOUS AT
THIS STAGE.
THIS IS A WALMART.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
SECURITY THEY HAVE AT THE DOOR
BUT IT WAS AN INSIDE THREAT.
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO STOP A
MANAGER HELL BENT ON WANTING TO
KILL EMPLOYEES SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE A NEVER ENDING
CONVERSATION ABOUT GUN CONTROL
BUT I THINK CARRIE AND I ARE
ALSO REFLECTING ON A SORT OF,
YOU KNOW, I THINK WE HAVE TO
ADMIT IT THAT WITHOUT THAT GUN
LEGISLATION, IT IS GOING TO TAKE
A STEPPING UP BY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS, FAMILY MEMBERS ABOUT
WHETHER SOMEONE IN THEIR MIDST
IS A THREAT.
THEY HAVE GOT TO CONSIDER THE
REST OF THE COMMUNITY AND NOT
WISH IT AWAY.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE NOW IN THE
ABSENCE OF CONTROL OVER GUN AND
GUN USAGE AND RESPONSIBLE GUN
OWNERSHIP AT THIS STAGE.